new in theaters this weekend angel has
fallen what will you see this is your
weekend ticket how long after this last
concussion did the migraine start pretty
much right away you need to be a lot
more careful and this third filming the
Olympus has fallen series and
continuation from London s fallen angel
has fallen stars Gerard Butler a Secret
Service agent Mike banning after an
attack while visiting the president is
accused of attempted assassination Mike
banning you're being charged with the
attempted murder of the President of the
United States don't you see that I'm
being set up
he's detained escapes and is now on the
run from the FBI and must clear his name
and find out what terrorist was trying
to assassinate the president it wasn't
me
the president's not safe then you try
and finish the job I am NOT gonna stop
until it proved who did this
[Music]
how did you find me I want security for
the president how do you think Dad I
need your help now that he's not working
for the man you can expect gb to get og
into survival instincts this movies for
you if you're a fan of the Olympus has
fallen series of movies you want a big
summer action movie or you've tried that
angel pick up one you know the one hey
hey so did it hurt did what hurt when
you fell from heaven Jared can you get
in here hey okay did it hurt the water
when you fell from heaven oh yeah
totally
sprained my wrist thanks for asking hey
is that did it hurt did did what hurt
when you fell from heaven
[Music]
then that is your weekend ticket well
you see and check back next week to see
Britney she runs a marathon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]